Welcome back to Computer Vision.
Today finally, finally,
finally we get to finish up on tracking.
We've discussed tracking a few ways
from the inference perspective
where we have a dynamics model, and you
know the whole bit now at this point.
Where we predict forward the state,
we take a measurement, and
we do our correction.
One was a Kalman filter where
essentially we have a specific
representation for our densities,
namely Gaussians and
all the world's a Gaussian.
Then we discussed,
particle filters where
because we're using samples you can
have much more arbitrary densities.
You just have to have enough
particles to represent them.
And also you need a generalized
censor model which works well.
For this last section just talk
about a couple more methods.
Just so
you should see that they're being done.
And then at the end, I'm going to
talk about some issues that show up
in tracking,
no matter how you're doing it.
And it's sort of outside of
the main tracking conversation and
yet, if you don't deal with
those issues, nothing works.